welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston Thor love and thunder released a
new scene that along with a higher
resolution and wider aspect ratio IMAX
version of the latest trailer like uh I
don't know I don't know how much lower
that frame could go we're already pretty
deep in that gutter I know I know I know
I know God's bless IMAX I'm gonna break
down all the new details that we have
learned and let's start with a new scene
from the film shown at the MTV Movie
Awards thus the cheering you hear in the
background
[Applause]
boy
you're bad
[Music]
[Applause]
yes this is the battle taking place in
New Asgard as the Asgardian troops the
an area are fight these creatures that I
think are the black Berserkers Unleashed
by Gore's sword all black the Necker
sword so Thor must have had a quick
sight in a mjolnir maybe it flew in from
out of nowhere it knocked a few
Berserkers off him and now he calls to
it like a dog whistling not unlike the
way yondu would whistle to summon his
yaka Arrow which is ironic since this
movie seems to be visiting yondu's home
world of Centauri 4 and his native
zatoan tribe reassembled mjolnir nearly
floats back to him but flings back to
Jane but I like how it still considers
for a moment to return to Thor's hand
suggesting Thor still has some pull over
it but that in this new reassembled form
it's more responsive to Jane I theorize
that could be because Jane's power-up
comes from a blessing from the cosmic
overseers like Infinity The Living
Tribunal The Watcher of death and Eon
the ones with the ultimate power to
promote beans from one tier of Godly
status to a Higher One Jane swings the
hammer or by its strap which I has
always loved as a way of a new wielder
showing their full Mastery of this
weapon like how right after cap first
lifted and caught the hammer in Avengers
end game as he charged toward Thanos he
swung Milner by his strap to build up a
charge let's move on to the recent
trailer in the new IMAX version of it
that was released including some 4K
quality footage allowing the blurrier
details to now come into sharp focus and
a wider aspect ratio allowing us to see
more of the frame unearthing some
interesting details that we didn't see
before like first in the shot of Thor's
showy arrival on the battle alongside
the Guardians on Satori 4. new little
detail I appreciated in the upper left
corner some tribal paintings on the
surface of that rock formation from The
zatoens ornamented Wisdom Tree to cord
telling these kids the legend of Thor
odinson I just love how much of the
culture we're getting of this
extraterrestrial Society whereas in the
past with planets like Hala and torfa it
was really just a big CGI background
characters people in costumes on
landscapes you don't really get to
explore or see much of another
interesting detail in this new aspect
ratio that might just be the angle
deceited me or some unfinished VFX not
sure yet but as Jane arrives into the
chamber with the statues as the cosmic
entities riding on that Pegasus you can
see the statue of Lady Death on the
lower left corner and the Living
Tribunal on the lower right but in this
shot in the shot where she lands the
living tribunal's face most visible
facing the far right is uncovered by the
hood now the Living Tribunal has three
faces a fully uncovered face
representing Equity a fully hooded base
representing necessity and a partially
covered or half-covered face
representing Revenge all three of these
faces must agree before the tribunal can
rule on anything so in effect there are
actually not five voices in this chamber
there are really seven with the Living
Tribunal having three votes in a sense
so in this first shot the face on the
far right is that of equity fully
uncovered the reason I bring this up is
that in the trailer is later shot when
Jane ignites the Hammer with lightning
the face on the far right is now the
half-covered face of Revenge so the
statue head has rotated it is possible
that this statue all of these statues
are not stationary lightless
representations of other beings but
rather themselves moving bigger so you
can actually talk to Jane with that
Living Tribunal head floating and slowly
spinning in place let's move on another
detail that we missed from before the
goat boat pulled by Thor's goats from
Norse mythology Tom grittier and Tang
Yost the goats have very different
appearances one lighter with simple
horns one with darker fur and spiraled
horns also in addition to this boat
having a neon signed cocktails and
dreams aside from Tom Cruise's movie
Cocktail now on the side of the boat you
can see its official name Edgar Edgar
was the god of the seas known as a
Devourer of ships like most Norse
mythology figures Edgar appears in the
Marvel Comics the Thor comics of the 80s
showing up at various Odin beasts but
this video is brought to you by the
ridge the ridge wallet is light and
sleek and Industrial it's designed to
fit in your front pocket unlike those
bulky old school wallets and make you
look like you're smugly in an 80s car
phone in your back pocket check it out
there are over 30 colors including
carbon fiber in burnt titanium it holds
up to 12 cards and still has room for
cash card
and gold dollars this is what they call
the black Damascus only the finest in my
front pockets every Ridge wallet comes
with a lifetime guarantee and they'll
let you test drive it for 45 days and
send it back for a full refund if you
don't love it the wallets have over 40
000 5 Star reviews it's made with an
RFID blocking technology that protects
you from those digital pickpocketers
they also have other cool products like
this commuter backpack it's weatherproof
and great for toting around a laptop
this month actually marks nine years
since the ridge started and they're
celebrating with a special sale so get
15 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com new rockstars that's ridge.com
new rockstars and use code new rockstars
find the link in the video's description
but speaking of the guides we can now
more clearly see the pantheon of gods
and Olympus and how some of them are
clearly larger in stature than others
organized in separate Opera boxes which
based on the way Zeus floats down to
Thor are actually detachable floating
platforms similar to the Coruscant
Senate chamber in Star Wars Jane helps
Thor break free from his custody on a
central Deus releasing mjolnir's broken
pieces in a cluster spray which is such
a cool new way of using this weapon in a
Range attack because each broken piece
presumably retains the full power of
mjolnir as a whole and then after that
spray she can presumably retract the
pieces back into its full cracked form
that way it's actually kind of a benefit
that mjolnir is in its broken cracked
state but during these fight shots you
can now see one of the larger gods in
the throne with an interesting headpiece
and based on Zeus's role in the mix of
gods from across cultures being
represented like we know one of them
will be boss AKA bastet from wakandan in
Egyptian mythology this may actually be
the Council of godheads from Thor Comics
also known as the council Elite Sky
fathers or All fathers it's a mix of
gods representing dozens of Earthly
pantheons overseen by Zeus but also
includes the Mayan God its Amna Egyptian
goddess Cyrus whom we saw in Moonlight
the Celtic god nuada Iroquois Spirit
Manitou Russian entity svarag in Aztec
deity
polka I butcher the pronunciation of any
of those I'm so sorry I will get better
but Mayan mythology potentially coming
into play here is actually very
significant as we are hearing increasing
rumors that black panther wakanda
forever will feature tanakuerta as Namor
art showing neymore and jaguar inspired
custom designs and Huerta recently
telling Vice that he has had to learn to
speak a Mayan language for many of his
lines so in the way Ryan coogler based
the wakandan's spoken language on HOSA a
South African dialect seems like he's
doing the same thing with the Atlantean
language based on Mayan and in Mayan
mythology itsana is the creator deity
depicted as a humanoid with an elaborate
headpiece but there are other Mayan
deities associated with Jaguars like
zabalian K again sorry if I mispronounce
that this is one of the Maya hero twins
who descended into the underworld or
what's known as God L the primary lord
of the underworld because Jaguars were
seen as having the ability to cross
between worlds as for the Maya daytime
and nighttime represented different
worlds this is always saying that as we
said before black panther may be
revealed in MCU as the Avatar of boss
and Namor may be an avatar for the Mayan
Jaguar deity and Atlantis may have been
a colony that sunk off the coast of the
on being a rival Kingdom to wakanda
perhaps the meteorite strike that gave
wakanda Mount bashenka could cause the
global earthquake that caused Atlantis
to sink into the ocean we're gonna find
out more of course when what kind of
forever makes its announcements but it
seems like love and thunder May begin to
set up that spiritual framework which is
very very exciting you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at EA bus follow
me rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
[Music]